what's poppin rock stars my name is mt
and after dancing in the rain of our
nerd tears of desperation for many
months sony pictures finally decided to
aggravate us agitated aractophiles no
longer releasing the trailer for
spider-man no way home or as i like to
call it underoos 3 lost in new york a
lot of new york's probably and good lord
did peter zendaya parker need to stop
talking because now these marvel
multiverse streets are no longer safe
from these eight-legged geeks like my
god if there was a petty olympics
mysterio would be decked out in gold
like quentin beck more like quintane
bolt
but like what the hell even happened
here like i knew things were probably
gonna go off the rails in this movie but
i did not know that we would not need
the rails at all but what exactly went
wrong with doctor strange's spell anyway
well well lucky for you speculation
nation i think that i have discovered
the mcu multiverse science behind this
big secret a science that has been
teased to us in previous marvel films
like spider-man far from home as well as
the very first doctor strange movie you
should have been paying attention
because oh my god i have been waiting so
long to say this sentence everything you
know about this trippy astral projection
sequence from doctor strange one is
wrong doctor strange is not traveling
through different universes he is
traveling to the gateway to the
multiverse let's talk about the initial
singularity my nerd babies i'm sorry
you're saying there's a multiverse
because i thought that was just
theoretical i mean that completely
changes how we understand the initial
singularity we're talking about an
internal inflation system
well while we thought that peter parker
was just being an e equals mc square he
was actually talking about the big bang
theory no not those eight-legged geeks
from tbs but remember the first words
from the theme song the whole universe
was in a hot damn space that is the
initial singularity the split second
before the big bang when all of the
energy and matter of the universe was
condensed into the size of like a proton
a very hot proton cell hoth of the
proton probably hasn't only fans this is
what we see doctor strange go through
along his journey to the doorway to the
multiverse and if you slow down the
spider-man no way home trailer right
after strange's spell starts to go
haywire you can see a condensed version
of that same journey through really
quick flash to break down that doctor
strange spell from the trailer we got a
first breakdown what the hell even
happened when we first took those mcu
shrooms back in 2016. so when the
ancient one first year to steven we see
him first escape upward in direct orbit
around our planet about to touch a
really pretty butterfly before the
ancient one tells chewie to punch it and
send steven to infinity and beyond
literally to infinity and beyond through
a wormhole through space and time first
leading him through a universe
propagated by stars that quickly changes
to a universe that is just these blue
green red and purple beams shooting out
of doctor strange finally leading
strange to the doorway of the initial
singularity surrounded by what i'm
assuming to be the dark matter from the
pre big bang dark world where malekith
lives like this is the very thing that
malekith hates the initial singularity
the light why does this happen in this
order because this is the reverse order
the universe was made after the big bang
first we have the initial singularity
where energy and matter are won then the
big bang blasts all the energy in the
universe out including the varying
concepts of space blue time green power
purple and reality red hence why
strange's limbs correspond to those
infinity stone colors and then later on
as the universe begins to cool that
energy converts itself to matter and
then we get planets and stars and pretty
much everything in our universe all the
physical stuff but why these four
because these four are the core of the
physical material universe according to
the mcu our universe cannot exist
without having a reality space to occupy
that reality time for us to live without
reality and power is just the energy of
the universe that is what caused
everything to exist the energy became
matter and all this should happen
but what about the mind well let's
continue on in our journey shall we so
while strange is on his way to the
singularity which i also think is where
the embers of genesis come from from
what if episode two that's a little
that's a side thing anyway he goes
through this tunnel while the ancient
one asked him what is real but notice
how his body is freaking out like the
ether from 4-2 this is because like i
said we are in the dark world period
right before the dark world's about to
end so the universe is complete darkness
because the laws of the universe have
yet to be born all of the laws of
reality are in this bubble that doctor
strange is headed to that's why they
call it a singularity a singularity is a
point of infinite potential like a black
hole is a singularity of like infinite
mass and the initial singularity is a
point of just where everything is it's
infinity that's why they call it the
infinity stones this is why all the
beams from dr strange hands converge
into the initial singularity before that
initial singularity opens up all those
laws of the reality of our universe are
in that bubble like the only things in
the dark pre big bang universe are
darkness dark matter the dark elves and
the ether slash reality stone because
the reason why the reality stone is
kool-aid to begin with is because there
is nothing but reality there's no space
there's no time there's no there's
nothing it's just realistic soup of
reality after strange finally goes
through the initial singularity
congratulations now we are inside the
big bang this means that dr strange has
shrunk down to ant-man sizes and
apparently is still shrinking until he
shrinks down to the root of existence
where the ancient one says mind and
matter meet as we learn in ant-man and
the wasp the quantum realm and the mind
are pretty much inextricably linked i
mean janet was able to communicate with
all of her family through scott and hank
rebuilt his entire house from his mind
while he was going mad in the quantum
realm and also why the environment seems
to change when hank and janet share
their kiss in the quantum realm their
thoughts and their feelings are
affecting their area around them just
real quick this video is brought to you
by the ridge the ridge wallet is like
sleek and industrial it's designed to
fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky back pocket wallets that we won't
talk about here because this is a ridge
wallet zone it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash the ridge wallet
comes in over 30 styles and colors
including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium that's how i like my titanium
burnt there's even an 18 karat gold
plated wallet if you're balling like
that which i think aisha and the other
shiny sovereign folks from guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 would appreciate
because they all about that gold life
they they be golden 24 7. and every
ridge wallet comes with a lifetime
guarantee and they'll let you test drive
it for 45 days and send it back for a
full refund if you don't love it but
that's highly improbable because they
make the best wallets and it's got 30
000 5 star reviews um they also have
great backpacks and travel bags with
rfid blocking pockets and optional
device charging batteries and they have
a cool event going on now where every
dollar spent on the website before
september 18th enters you to win a 2020
jeep gladiator or fifty thousand dollars
if you prefer cash and are really
excited to paint yourself gold to match
your new ridge wallet because that's
what you do but you know just don't
affect yourself with chemicals
so get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge
r-i-d-g
dot com slash new rockstars and use the
code new rockstars and you can find the
link in the video description below of
course i think that the reason why
strange's environment keeps creepily
changing in the scene is because strange
has shrunk to the absolute root of
existence meaning that he is even
smaller than we have seen any pym shrink
before he shrunk himself to the very
realm of the mind this is an entirely
conceptual space where the environment
responds to what strange is thinking
about the second strain starts worrying
about those weird faces hands come out
and grab him because he's scared he's
fearing for his life because he's
thinking about hands his hands are
growing hands because your mind makes
your reality this is extremely important
now because this is both why doctor
strange spell does not work in
spider-man no way home and why doctor
strange 2 is called doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness because my
nerd babies the realm of the mind is the
doorway to the multiverse as represented
by strange going through this einstein
rosen bridge in his eyeball and smashing
through this weird glass prism brothers
sisters and gender labels resistors of
the speculation nation i'm proud to
present to you the multiverse because
this is the multiverse each of these
weird glass prism thingies is a
different universe like what strange
broke out of was the confines of the mcu
universe and then he broke into
dormammu's dark universe where nothing
makes any freaking sense this is why the
avengers needed pym particles to time
travel like they shrank so small that
they were able to hop to other timeline
slash universes in this manner but when
strange does it he uses the initial
singularity because like the mcu has
tried to tell us since the very
beginning magic is just science that we
don't understand your ancestors called
it magic and you call it science
when i come from a place where they're
one in the same thing doctor strange is
essentially doing what the avengers did
but with magic he hacks the source code
of the universe to use the magic that he
derives from the multiverse to travel
through space and time through the
singularity so that he can travel
through the multiverse if he wanted to
so because peter parker interrupted
strange's spell with his confusion about
his dual life everything inside of
strange's incantation circle journeyed
through the initial singularity and
popped back into the sanctum basement
from another reality because you have to
keep in mind that the sanctum sanctorum
is probably a staple of every single you
know multiverse reality this is why this
movie is called no way home these two
heroes are probably in whatever universe
peter's confused and fractured
spider-man essentially tuned into and
peter's goal throughout this entire
movie is trying to find his way back to
his native mcu universe while running
into some of our favorite sony
spider-man villains along the way
because the word spider-man was used in
the spell there you have it marvel
multiverse science i told y'all we were
marvel scientists in this [ __ ] i told
you guys y'all didn't believe me but
yeah what do you guys think do you guys
think that i have finally cracked the
secret of the marvel multiverse before
you know spider-man no way home and
multiverse of madness or do you think
that you know something else is going on
and peter is not actually in a different
universe let me know what you guys think
in the comment section down below thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at mastertainment if
you want to see me tweet some really
weird [ __ ] about marvel because that's
what i do with 24 7 but most importantly
you can follow new rockstars wherever we
are on social media and when you do that
on youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time i upload a
video because we do that pretty much
every day and of course do not forget to
hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so you can
get cool and dope ass shirts like this
and all sorts of cool like you know we
got suicide squad shirts got all sorts
of dope stuff so if you want to let that
nerd flag fly go to new
rockstarsmerch.com because we got it
baby we got it all we got all of it but
anyways thanks so much again for
watching and i love you guys and i'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you